je veux pas me lever je veux pas y aller
8h ce matin il y a pas de solution parce
que en fait il y a pas de problème à
régler et genre tu es là tu pleures tu
sais pas pourquoi tu te dis mais meufs
mais qu'est-ce qui t'arrive en fait
voilà je crois qu'il y aura que des
vidéos je suis dans un monde de merde
c'est vraiment pas stable en fait parce
que là j'ai arrêté de chialer et je me
casse je vais voir une pote
je suis même pas sûr si j'ai envie qu'on
regarde ces vidéos
salut c'est Juliette et elle c'est Luna
sur les réseaux sociaux on parle de plus
en plus de la dépression en France on
estime que près de une personne sur cinq
à souffert ou souffrira d'une dépression
au cours de sa vie et Luma fait partie
de ces personnes mais elle n'est pas
seule dans son combat j'ai lancé une
messagerie pour avoir vos retours par
rapport aux expériences de la dépression
et vous êtes très nombreux à vous sentir
comme mal bonjour
je suis en train de mélodies de tous mes
amis j'ai des amis extraordinaires mais
j'ai même plus envie de les voir
je pense
que je souffre de dépression mais c'est
la première fois que j'ose mettre les
termes là-dessus à votre
vie de mourir et j'ai le soir avec la
même envie on souffre tous les jours
c'est toute une nouvelle vie qui se
construit de cette façon qui se base sur
la dépression certains pensaient suicide
votre président des addictions pour
compter ça
de se sentir pas soutenu par ses parents
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'horri
parce que je me tiens en fait c'est
censé être les personnes qui m'aiment le
plus au monde et ils sont là en fait en
train de me dénigrer et j'en suis même
obligé de leur mentir en fait pour ne
pas leur dire que que je vais mal je
commençais à pleurer vraiment tous les
jours j'avais absolument plus du tout
confiance en moi mais vraiment plus du
tout mon message ils sont super
poignants et ils sont touchants mais il
y en a qui sont super inquiétants et du
coup j'y reviendrai en fin de vidéo pour
en parler un peu plus pour comprendre ce
que c'est vraiment une dépression on va
écouter le lendemain je l'ai rencontré
il y a quelques mois via son compte Tik
Tok
[Musique]
elle le tient avec une amie à elle en
octobre dernier le massif hospitalisé
une dixième fois pour ces troubles
psychiatriques elle a 18 ans et c'est là
en psychiatrie qu'elle a rencontré Viki
et qu'elles ont décidé de lancer un
compte TikTok ensemble parce qu'elle
s'ennuyait mais surtout parce qu'elle
voulait documenter leur maladie vous
m'avez demandé de vous faire une vidéo
sur les différences entre les idées
noires et les idées suicidaires en fait
ça fait longtemps que je voulais parler
de ce sujet déjà c'est quelque chose
dont on parle beaucoup avec mes potes et
puis c'était le sujet le plus demandé
dans mes DM sur Instagram du coup je me
suis dit ok on parle souvent de la
dépression mais sans savoir exactement
ce que ça entraîne et beaucoup de gens
qui en souffrent se sentent souvent mis
à part et pas légitimes dans le ressenti
du coup pour qu'on comprenne le
quotidien d'une personne en dépression
j'ai demandé à Louma de se filmer et
elle a accepté
[Musique]
enfin bref voilà c'est pas la forme mais
c'est quoi la dépression
[Musique]
c'est un peu compliqué parce que c'est
ça varie en fonction des personnes à mes
yeux c'est une période où tu as un peu
l'impression en fait de
perdre toute ta vitalité c'est la
première vidéo que je fais sur le coup
je sais pas si je suis super à l'aise
avec l'idée
je suis capable de rien je peux pas
ranger je peux pas manger
plus rien rien de tout ce qui est normal
pour des gens se lever à aller se laver
manger je peux rien faire
tu as plus envie tu as plus rien qui te
fait plaisir c'est beaucoup de fatigue
mentale et physique aussi et en même
temps tu te sens pas légitime de dire
bah là je sors là je suis heureuse je
suis avec mes potes je suis bien et même
si au fond c'est toujours compliqué dans
ces moments-là
on peut passer des moments et
gérant qui m'a filé un [ __ ] d'avocat
parce que j'avais la dalle et au final
on s'est retrouvé avec Laura ouais viens
boire un coup avec moi voilà donc là on
va boire un coup tous ensemble on m'a
déjà fait la remarque mais regarde là tu
es en train de rigoler avec tes copains
tu sors tu es pas en dépression bah
ouais je rigolais avec mes copains je
sors mais au fond je suis pas bien donc
c'est les gens se fient à ce qu'ils
voient et ils savent pas ce qui se
passait à l'intérieur donc c'est
compliqué
je n'ai rien fait rien absolument rien
je suis resté au lit
petite elle est curieuse et super active
elle fait plein de sport comme du tennis
des sports de combat etc à 8 ans elle
quitte sa maison pour partir en internat
à 2h de chez elle et à 11 ans son papa
quitte la France et même s'il se parle
encore un peu aujourd'hui sur l'absence
la beaucoup marqué à l'époque
à 12 ans elle se fait virer de son
collège pour des problèmes de
comportement et dans son nouvel internat
où elle ne connaît personne elle
commence à se scarifier les bras à
partir de ce moment-là j'ai vu une
psychologue qui m'a tout de suite dit
bah au vu de ce que vous me racontez des
actes que vous avez envers vous ce
serait peut-être bien qu'on vous
hospitalise et à partir de ce moment-là
ça a été très très long parce qu'il y a
12 ans on peut pas dire à quelqu'un
vous avez tel ou tel maladie mais le
problème c'est que un diagnostic ça
prend ça peut prendre jusqu'à 10 ans à
partir du moment où tu es majeur Luma
elle a 14 ans et ses deux ans après sa
première scarification elle passe tout
l'été 2018 dans un hôpital psychiatrique
mais en vrai ça lui fait pas beaucoup de
bien parce que les docteurs ils lui
disent que c'est une crise d'ado alors
que l'omale sait qu'elle se sent super
mal et deux ans plus tard elle fait sa
première TS c'est à dire tentative de
suicide pour les gens c'est juste genre
la flemme je reste au lit et je pleure
c'est la crise d'ado c'est normal tu te
cherches tu sais pas vraiment quitter
donc c'est normal que tu sois un peu
triste et quand tu essayes d'expliquer à
ces gens là que ouais enfin ça dure
depuis que j'ai 11 12 ans je vais en
avoir 19 au bout d'un moment je pense
que c'est beaucoup plus profond et les
gens te disent non mais c'est dans ta
tête fait un effort va faire un peu de
sport et puis ça ira mieux quoi depuis
sa première hospitalisation à 14 ans
Loma a été hospitalisé 10 fois pour des
séjours de deux semaines à trois mois à
cause de toutes ces absences elle a
redoublé sa seconde et sa première
niveau vie amical c'est difficile
beaucoup de ses potes la lâchent parce
que c'est dur à gérer des changements
d'humeur et ces annulations la dernière
minute je viens de me réveiller et j'ai
prévu de partir avec une pote
doit prendre le train dans une heure
et comme d'hab jusqu'à la dernière
minute j'étais trop épais
et là j'ai qu'une envie en fait c'est de
me tirer une belle
chiant
de faire des trucs trop bien j'ai mon
cœur et mon cerveau
ça vient amoureuse et compliqué aussi
elle a une copine pendant un peu plus
d'un an mais ça finit par se terminer
parce que c'est pas simple d'être avec
quelqu'un qui est en dépression
inconsciemment dans les moments où tes
pavillon tu fais énormément souffrir les
gens autour de toi par le fait que tu
t'isoles tu parles pas les gens voient
que tu vas mal et il se sentent
impuissant on va te proposer quelque
chose tu vas dire oui et à la dernière
minute tu vas dire absolument pas en
fait genre là je le sens pas et les gens
comprennent pas et les gens te disent te
font culpabiliser sans le vouloir en
disant bah ouais mais regarde c'est pas
cool tu m'as dit que tu venais au final
tu viens pas quand j'étais à Bordeaux
j'ai rencontré une de ses copines
l'hôpital qui est resté ami avec elle
elle se sont rencontrées dans un lycée
alternatif qui essaye d'accompagner des
élèves en difficulté
[Musique]
trois mois vu qu'on évolue tous un peu
ensemble et il y a ce truc de grandir
comme une famille ça peut je sais que ça
peut aussi être compliqué quand tu
arrives et que tu sais pas ce qui s'est
passé tout le monde a passé trois mois
ensemble à évoluer ensemble a vécu des
choses ensemble moi j'arrive au bout de
trois mois je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé je comprends pas tout et là on te
regarde on dit bah ouais mais en même
temps tu étais pas là pendant trois mois
donc on va pas s'arrêter de vivre pour
toi tu vois j'essaie de la motiver et
d'être là pour elle le plus que je peux
et qu'elle soit heureuse
même si c'est pas facile tous les jours
mais bon je sais que je la laisserai pas
comme d'autres personnes dont tu le fais
parce que je sais ce que ça fait et que
j'ai pas envie qu'elle vive la même
chose que je suis attaché à elle donc je
veux juste que elle aille mieux et bien
en fait vu que l'humain ne parle pas
souvent de ses problèmes et communique
peu ça rend les choses difficiles pour
sa famille l'humain en est consciente
elle ne leur donne pas les moyens
d'aider et du coup eux ils ne savent pas
quoi faire j'ai eu des moments où même
les gens de ma famille au goûté un
moment me disaient mais c'est horrible
il faisait des comparaisons ils me
disait regarde les gens qui vivent la
guerre ils ont pas le temps d'être en
dépression ils ont pas le temps d'être
soignés tu te sens hyper seul quand même
ta famille comprends plus que tes amis
disent ouais mais là fait un effort et
même des fois mon psychiatre m'a dit je
peux rien faire pour toi je peux
absolument rien faire pour toi donc là
tu dis je suis toute seule toute seule
quoi
c'est pas super super fun là je profite
d'avoir un élan de
lucidité on va dire j'ai une préparé je
vais sortir pour essayer de
simuler mon cerveau
aujourd'hui son traitement c'est 10
médicaments par jour dont des
anxiolytiques des régulateurs d'humeur
et des somnifères une infirmière vient
chez elle tous les jours pour lui
déposer le nombre exact de médicaments
car elle n'a pas le droit d'avoir des
pilules chez elle par précaution Luma
elle a encore beaucoup de chemin à faire
avant de se sentir mieux elle est pas
sûr qu'elle pourra passer le bac cette
année et ça voudrait dire qu'elle doit
redoubler une troisième fois j'aurais
bien voulu plus vous montrer ses amis et
ces moments positifs mais en ce moment
elle est assez seule et pas très motivée
pour sortir évidemment cet état ça
n'aide pas à vivre la même vie que les
autres jeunes de 18 ans mais Loma elle
garde l'espoir que les choses vont
s'améliorer pour elle
ça fait cinq ans que je suis suivie j'ai
l'impression de pas avancer et au fond
de moi j'ai la rage genre je veux
avancer je veux m'en sortir et j'ai
l'impression d'être bloqué genre
le seul obstacle dans tout ça c'est
moi-même
travailler en psychiatrie parce que le
fait d'y passer énormément de temps
ça m'a donné envie de d'aider les autres
et de leur montrer que ouais c'est
possible en fait accroche-toi ça va être
dur accroche-toi mais ça va aller
pour terminer cette vidéo je voulais
parler des messages les plus inquiétants
que j'ai reçu sur les messagerie de brut
en fait il y en a beaucoup que j'ai
trouvé très troublant parce qu'il y
avait énormément de messages avec des
intentions suicidaires évidemment je
vais pas vous les faire écouter mais
comme tous ces messages sont anonymes
j'ai pas pu mettre en contact leur
auteur avec des gens qui pourraient les
aider moi je suis pas psy ni médecin
évidemment mais si j'ai un conseil c'est
ne pas rester seul et d'en parler autour
de vous et si jamais vous n'avez pas
envie d'en parler avec vos proches il y
a un numéro gratuit et anonyme que vous
pouvez appeler pour recevoir les
soutiens c'est le 31 14 prenez soin de
vous on se voit bientôt pour la
prochaine vidéo et comme toujours
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer un message sur
Instagram pour d'autres idées de sujets
même si je peux pas répondre à tout le
monde je les lis tous et je les vois et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai
réalisé cette vidéo si vous avez trouvé
cette vidéo intéressante vous pouvez
vous abonner à notre chaîne YouTube
à la prochaine
[Musique]